let me let me let me tell you about um
what's a good deterrent for keeping
urban city city urban liberal types out
we have the story from timcast.com ohio
becomes 23rd state to pass
constitutional permit less concealed
carry gun law
ohio joins a number of other states to
uphold the second amendment right of
private citizens bravo ohio welcome to
the club west virginia of course
constitutional carry i love it because
that means that uh if you're armed in
west virginia you can pop over to ohio
no big deal because it's all
constitutional care you don't have to
worry about that's the way it should be
but man
and the state laws are so great because
the problem is if you try to if the if
the country were to separate in some
sort of civil war there's no way to draw
that line because the democrats live in
cities there are no democrats there are
no blue states there's only blue cities
right and so you'd have to create some
crazy border line that just somehow
encapsulates all the cities
they'd be they'd be cut off in seconds
but they can't create their own uh
democratic enclaves within states when
you talk about these issues like guns
and abortion those this still apply in
the cities no matter what they do when i
talk to my friends about uh
you know concealed carry when i talk to
mike more my more liberal gun controlly
people i know
uh
it's funny because they can't fathom why
it would be a good thing and it's like
worrying to them and i love tweeting it
just triggering the left i'm like more
guns buy guns and they're like oh and
they get all angry and um
i don't want to say the dude's name but
one of those activists like i tweeted
about everyone should buy a gun or
something like that or it was something
silly trolley where i was like more guns
you know guns for everyone and then he
got like all offended and scared and i'm
just you know i answered my friends
they're like why should so why is a good
thing and i was like that
regular people have the same rights as
the politicians
like do you think politicians should
have special privileges that regular
people don't do you think powerful
corporations should have special
privileges people don't do you think
billionaires should have special
privileges people don't well guess what
the billionaires walk around with guns
the billionaires got armed security the
millionaires got armed security the
politicians got guns the politicians got
armed security politicians are allowed
to carry in dc you're not so when they
pass constitutional carry i see it as a
great normalizer you want you want this
is the united states we're all equals
it's a representative government that
you nancy pelosi is no more politically
powerful on legally than you or i now on
paper and the way
reality and society works of course
she's got political power and clout and
all that stuff the point is if if you
know i grew up in chicago
politicians are armed
armed security you screw you in one of
the worst gun crime you know cities one
of the worst gun crime states an oscar
that everybody has a right to keep and
bear arms let's equalize it if you get
to so do i
i love it it's pretty awesome because if
the fall of the roman republic if the
citizens have been armed caesar may not
have been able to overthrow that
republic probably wouldn't have been
able to so it's obvious that we live in
a deeply divided country we just have
different opinions and they're probably
not reconcilable the idea of a national
divorce is probably pretty obviously a
pretty radical and
untenable probably proposition but one
of the things we can do now at the local
level is incorporate new towns so if you
live in a large county um like where i
live in fairfax virginia especially
basically all of the south i think it
grew out of the plantation system the
counties are the primary
governments now it's different in places
like new jersey where you already have
these little towns but a lot of people
live in these sprawling county regions
and one thing you can do is start
incorporating new towns and smaller
local governments that better reflect
your needs so if you want to live in a
communist utopia go for it and if you
want to live right next door in the in
the in the right leaning town go for it
but um states republican states can
empower basically to create a new city
that can have its own police force its
own laws its own prosecutor its own
everything tax rate um you usually need
to be granted a charter from the state
so what republican legislatures need to
do is say look if any geographical
boundary and you can create you're on
your own you can just say look these 100
square blocks or whatever draw your own
boundary on a map you put it on a ballot
you get a referendum if 51 percent of
people want to form a new town boom you
have a new town you run it the way you
want
so we got freedom stand out in west
virginia i think you need 100 people
residents to form a town
is that is that what it is maybe so then
uh we'll we'll once we reach that number
of people we'll be like how would you
like to be a city and then you know
we'll incorporate for damastan and then
we'll have a town and then we'll start
creating laws like you can't censor
people and of course a town of 100
people will still have very little
weight against the might of say twitter
or whatever but it'll be really
interesting to see how our city's police
force deals with filing you know legal
paperwork with the state they're in
violation of city law how they'll
respond to it and of course schools is
that is one of the big ones here that's
because schools will be fun you know
because we're gonna like everyone will
basically agree on what schools are
supposed to be what they should be pod
schooling
that kind of well no i mean like if we
have a school district and we
incorporate a town we're going to be
like crt get out like i don't care if
you teach kids about the like so i we we
we talked with one of our guests about
this because he was like you want you
want to ban people learning about
critical race theory and i'm like no no
we wanna ban the indoctrination of kids
under the the ideology of critical race
theory if you came to me and said i
would like my child to read a book about
critical race theory and the bible and
marx and um you know which one was uh um
adam smith
the whatever if they want to read out of
smith i'd be like by all means let's
teach the children about the ideology of
adam smith and karl marx let's teach
them about the ideology of these
critical race theorists
not indoctrinate them well let's teach
them basic math first because we haven't
managed to even do that yet yeah no no
absolutely what i mean
it's funny how we're having a
conversation about complex ideological
ideas when these kids in these in these
in fourth grade should be learning
division and that's the issue with all
this stuff in the schools it's designed
to distract from the fact that we've got
11 kids proficient in american history
24 in math 36 in reading those are
deeply embarrassing so we bring critical
race theory in and it says tests aren't
real objectivity isn't a real thing
wanting the right answer is a function
of whiteness it's really just a
distraction it's all about the the whole
um debate over critical race theory has
really been a bit of a um like a
distraction that's the whole it's all it
comes down to the academics or when
you're doing your book race to the
bottom does that would you just
constantly uncover it like what were you
uncovering when it came to the
distraction of cr yeah i mean that's
what i thought it was firstly you know
like the shutdown was insane you know so
many families were devastated like how
are you supposed to work and watch your
kids at the same time does anyone even
care and then of course crt but when i'm
looking into it like our kids are our
country is so screwed because our kids
do not know math they don't know how to
read and write what is going to happen
and we're not talking about way out in
the distant future um those statistics i
just mentioned are for 12th graders so
they're going to be voting next year
they're going to be employed next year
um this is the most imminent national
security threat to our country math is
interesting it's a language i think of
it as like if you if you miss a week of
homework and you don't follow like what
the term means then when they use the
term next week you don't know what
they're talking about and you have to
learn the language as you go yeah so
like if you missed three or four days of
math it's hard to catch up without
learning because they teach you terms
they're giving you language a language
class basically um whereas history you
can just pop in and start learning and
then if you miss a spot you can kind of
fill in the guesses math is a tough one
this is one of the problems i have with
school man to be completely honest that
it's like everyone must learn at the
exact same pace or else yes or too slow
are left behind and those are two a
quick but sit there bored and confused
and frustrated yeah it just doesn't work
it's terrible i raised my hand and they
would just pass over me because i kept
raising my hand over and over i'm like
why isn't anyone answering i know and
these are the people that love diversity
but they don't
they argue that people are actually not
diverse when it comes to that we've all
got to learn the same thing at the same
time and you know
it's equity is equal outcomes by race
and things like that and you get equal
equal outcomes by bringing down the top
performers to the lowest the level of
the lowest common denominator and at
this stage in america that's actually
very very low cut out the tallgrass
20 of people are proficient in 12th
grade math that are graduating these are
graduating students 24 yep
wow and it's not hard to be professional
it's a pretty low bar algebra i could
see how algebra was confusing if you've
never learned variables
geometry i mean well look at this angle
stuff trigonometry is little let's be
real
when you live in the pod hooked up to
the metaverse and they're they're
funneling bug protein mush into your gut
straight through a tube and you live in
the realm of skyrim or elder scrolls or
whatever and uh you have no idea what
the real world is like you're not gonna
care about any of this
yeah have you guys ever um
talked about or heard about the
philanthropic foundations like the
creepy history of the ford foundation
and things like that
i think you'd be interested in that um
part of when i'm researching all this
school stuff crt
i i think it really comes from those
foundations which are like you're
watching pbs and you'll hear you know
this segment brought to you by the
macarthur foundation or you go to like
the art museum and it's like oh funded
by you know the ford foundation it's
like okay these are just some nice old
rich people whatever never thought about
it before these are the most important
and secretive and creepy forces in
american politics they are so powerful
uh and they all collude so you've got a
bunch of billion dollar organizations
all working together and so you think
back to the early 1910s you've got
carnegie he's got a vertical monopoly on
steel
ford obviously doing the auto stuff it's
a bunch of monopolists and teddy
roosevelt comes along and trusts bus
monopolies are a bad thing so the
families all stash their money in these
tax exempt foundations that live in
perpetuity because they're just spending
the dividends so they live forever this
this wealth of these monopolists from
100 years ago is preserved forever in
eternity
um
the thing is okay so they're all
capitalists and now the foundations are
doing
trying to overthrow capitalism which is
ironic um but there were also racist
creeps they were capitalist racist
creeps from 100 years ago um and so
you might have heard about like kellogg
brothers i don't know i think there's
like a documentary about one
really creepy guy he's like um
uh i don't know like he
didn't he made corn flakes to stop kids
from cranking it right yes yes weird
stuff about masturbation all that kind
of stuff did he promote circumcision in
the u.s or am i thinking of somebody
else i don't know but he was at the same
time all these little boys
so he thought yes
corn flakes would do something about it
weird stuff with circumcision
circumcision yeah and so their whole
thing was they were these progressive
elites that wanted to make the world a
better place and they to do that they
thought we should get rid of black
people um and so their thing was
eugenics and they you know
they lobbied they got laws passed that
you could sterilize defective people
people with mental retardation um and
essentially minorities they went over to
puerto rico and they sterilized a third
of the women over there so they you can
reproduce hispanic population into wow
american citizens um and so
by the 1940s the rockefeller foundation
had this
um
seven acre warehouse on long island
where they had boxes showing the family
trees of every american family for the
purposes of seeing who had good genes
and which had genes we should get rid of
um these are creeps social engineering
creeps um you know fast forward they
continue doing similarly racist stuff
and it kind of evolves with the time it
uses different language to hide it so by
like the 1990s they're still trying to
get rid of black people but they're
doing it through abortion
and so they're they're really targeting
the black community for abortion
um anyway so that's the history of the
fact
they touch on a lot of aspects of life
that i came across them through them
pushing critical race theory in the
schools and society at large but um i
know it sounds like a conspiracy theory
but it's true and if people don't
understand it because the foundations
don't they're not the forward-facing
they have fronts they give money to
these other groups that then do the
thing
but it's not like they're just donating
to groups that were already going to do
that anyway what they do is they'll say
well we're looking to fund xyz and
suddenly everyone with a non-profit says
we've got a grant proposal to do that
we're applying and so they steer the
direction of america by signaling what
they're going to put money at and then
all these activists do exactly that
that's so terrific hold on i want to ask
so you're saying they had family trees
of every american family did i miss hear
that i i i don't know exactly how
comprehensive it was it was
extraordinarily comp comprehensive um
and that was the gist of it yeah
however ancestry
yeah dna 23andme or whatever they call
it impact investing what these
what these organizations have been doing
and the idea is you you put money in a
sector until someone bites and then you
basically create a sector you you and
it's going to be 21st century
devastation impact economy is on its way
this is something um allison mcdowell
talks a lot about it's
definitely you see it on youtube where
people were like even just getting
people getting funded
like you make a video about x x gets
more views you might want to make
another video about x who knows where
there's user bots or what but somebody
is giving you that impact it's really
really easy to uh throw money behind a
youtuber that you like and allow them to
keep doing it through the shadows you
can so i i haven't i haven't used
youtube ads in some years uh but back in
the day when i was you know you know
working in more in marketing you could
go on youtube find a youtuber channel
you wanted to advertise on and advertise
directly on their channel that means
you're funding them directly without
them realizing it whether you whether
it's intentional or not maybe you're
like hey i want to sell these you know
rokhamsakam you know robot things
modeled after the young turks so you'd
put it on their channel so that their
fans would buy it that also means that
you could buy garbage ads for no reason
and just put a thousand dollars into
their channel which they get a portion
of i think 65 or 70
so there's ways to like shadow fund
certain personalities you like so it
used to be that when it came to
journalism
they wouldn't go to a journalist and say
do as you're told or else they would
find someone who already wrote lies and
say want a job
nowadays what they do is they find
youtube channels that fit the agenda or
what they like and
you know they make sure the advertising
money is going good for them and they
don't realize that these youtube
channels that are doing well don't
realize they're actually being funded by
these organizations yeah but going back
to what you were saying about these
left-wing progressive organizations that
from the get-go were involved with the
eugenics project
it's interesting because the left likes
to play this game where anytime you
point to something that the progressive
movement did in the past they say well
that was conservative or more
conservative because it happened in the
past but we as modern progressives don't
believe in that so a progressive at that
time would not have been on that side of
the issue despite the fact that the
progressives of that era were quite
clearly on that particular side of the
issue and so the left can pick up any
horrific idea they want and when it
turns out to be a complete disaster for
everyone instead of losing any
credibility they just get to say well no
no we're forward thinking so we tried
that it didn't work but that's
completely missing the point we have to
be careful about which new ideas we're
willing to try out because they can be
absolutely disastrous if you haven't
vetted them properly and it's no mystery
that many of the most horrific tragedies
to befall humankind in the 20th century
were a result of progressive thinking
especially centralized thinking
centralizing
eugenics is massively dangerous i
understand like the idea of finding a
spouse that you want to procreate with
and that's a form of eugenics like
you're choosing your bloodline stuff so
that's like that's okay that's not too
far but when you become the authority
and you're like i want these people to
have sex with these people and these
people never to have kids that's danger
danger cause who's in making those that
call you should watch attack on titan oh
i haven't seen it past and i think you
might have a series of walls i hear
jordan peterson ai told told people to
watch it yeah so uh someone kept super
chatting us jordan peterson said to
watch attack on titan and so i was like
i hear good things i'll watch it then i
did if you're interested in the idea of
eugenics if you're interested in the
idea of white privilege and critical
race theory you're critical of these
things seriously watch attack on titan
it's crazy because uh it's an anime and
my only real understanding of the show
was like oh it's about there's this one
last city with three big walls that keep
out giant humanoid monsters that eat
people called titans and there are
people that have these like rope systems
that allow them to move around really
quickly and use swords to kill giant
monsters yeah i like anime you know full
metal alchemist was pretty awesome i was
a big fan of naruto but i was like eh
maybe i'll watch it then when i heard
the robot of jordan peterson robot tell
me to watch it in the super chat
i decided to watch it then i realized
it's actually a political thriller that
touches on the ideas of eugenics of
ancestral sin
and oppression and white privilege and
it tackles all these ideas
man it's some it's it's good stuff and
war when there's like warring countries
and then you know there's one little
girl and she's like you people are evil
your ancestors oppressed us you have any
idea how many people you've murdered
your family deserve to die and the other
girl goes my mom didn't do any of those
things she never hurt a single person
why was she killed i'm just like if
jordan peterson did watch it he really
would tell people to watch it because
like the the white privilege element of
it and the authoritarianism i was like
man it really is a good show plus
there's giant humanoid monsters that
fight each other so you get that yeah
but you're it's really interesting to
hear you say it that way i mean they
essentially the the far left views
conservative as just a different word
for bad yeah so when they do bad things
they were being conservative even if
they were
explicitly doing them in the name of
progressive ideology which they were i
mean back in the 1910s there was this
sense of what do you call it no bless i
believe uh belize you know the rich
people well they wanted to use their
wealth to make the world a better place
and they had this trust in science which
became social science and so they
started doing this weird studies and so
the ford foundation wiretapped a jury
room in a major criminal trial and spot
illegally spied on americans um they
made a little spreadsheet and wrote
their little phd style paper on why
essentially we shouldn't have juries in
america because people are stupid um and
so these are a bunch of uh you know
college professor types that think they
know better than everyone um and there
is this that's the really the
progressive ideologies that we know
better if we could master plan
everything the world would be a better
place and so that's really what the
eugenics came from
and there was no moment i mean i would
maybe buy it if they said there was some
moment where the foundation shifted from
conservative to liberal and we
apologized and there was this
transformation but you can go through
every decade they do the same thing
in the 60s they went into new york city
and they had this idea that we should
have segregated schools in the black
neighborhoods and they said well really
what we want is integration but the
blacks are going to have to prove
that they're capable of living in our
society first and so they use that
bizarre logic to actually take new york
city backwards and create segregated
schools and they had them do very
similar stuff to what we're doing in the
schools now where it's all like
self-directed learning no one's actually
sitting them down and actually teaching
things and so the result was predictable
like the kids did horrible they pitched
it like these these poor kids in harlem
are going to be reading james joyce
because they choose to that's not what
happened the schools failed and they
they blamed the asians somehow because
the asians had nothing to do with it but
they blamed them um
and so their excuse was look we're we're
the liberal ford foundation we wanted to
integrate new york city but we had to do
the opposite and segregate it and so now
you have critical race theory where
they're saying you know showing up on
time and working hard and um
determination doing homework those are
all not part of black culture they're
white attributes it's the exact same
thing there was no reckoning there was
no shift from conservative to liberal
they're
the the language has changed but the
result is the exact same it's the
perpetuation of this elite um status quo
and you know the surest way to keep uh
you know a black underclass in place is
to make sure they don't learn uh basic
academics wow extremely well said um
extremely well said have you written
about these foundations extensively
because i'd love to read more about that
that's that's part of my book race to
the bottom it's a book about schools but
it's one of those things you start
looking into schools and you go down
this rabbit hole like everything so
there's this you know there's a million
because people think it's all about
loudon and that's like one of the
weirdest things i just wrote about
loudoun because that's where i live
right i mean there's other reporters
that happened they did the same thing
we're all just being lazy honestly and
looking at our own school district
because it's easiest um the schools the
problems are are everywhere and um
there's a there's a nationalizing
element to it right there's 13 000
school districts how is the same weird
stuff happening in all of them and
that's where i i came upon the
foundations yeah well and the
interesting thing is is that even in red
states in places like west virginia
we're seeing school boards get taken
over by cult members and what happens is
when they run for school board for they
don't say they're democrat or republican
they lie or they just you know keep it
under wraps so we're gonna teach your
kids and then as soon as they get in
it's
wokeness yeah it's interesting you were
being a little bit self-deprecating and
you said you looked at your own school
system because that was easier and
you're being lazy but i would argue that
that's exactly why we need to have a
system which encourages people looking
at their own system and what's local to
them because it is easier to solve
problems on the local level but for
whatever reason we've really
spread a way of thinking throughout our
culture that you have to be paying
attention to what's happening in every
other part of the country except for
yours yeah and i mean a couple like back
in 2019 i mean i so i spent my career as
a
you know dc journalist and i thought i'm
like at the you know in the center of it
covering congress covering all this
important stuff and i realized like
local government is actually more
important so i just straight up quit my
job and started focusing on this local
stuff because no one was paying
attention to it and that gives i mean
and honestly it's a little silly that a
lot of us in america sit around and
talk about our opinion of the president
and things like that um when we can't
really have much of a say like the
average joe um but where the average
joke and have a say is at the local
level and yet we just thought it was
boring we thought it was lame and no one
was doing anything and created this
vacuum that was filled by a bunch of
creeps well and it's interest well they
know that the average joe can have an
effect at the local level which is
exactly why they try to smear people
like the man whose daughter was raped
and tried to stand up to the school
board about it and it's why they want
the fbi to classify parents who speak
out against the sp school board or speak
up for their children as terrorists
did that dad like make a mistake by
getting angry and screaming
who couldn't uh yeah no i think he was
actually more restrained than probably
the average person would be and you know
he didn't come forward and tell a story
even after that that's it wasn't until i
called him and he tried to have faith in
the system but the prosecutor wound up
trying to put him in jail for disorderly
conduct and this is a blm soros
soros-funded prosecutor who ran on a
campaign of she let like an attempted
murderer out like the week before um you
know they don't she's one of these no
bail types no one gets jailed for
disorderly and so they targeted him and
he still had faith in the system and it
wasn't until the second girl was raped
because i already knew about it by that
point but he didn't want me to come
forward he was that kind of guy he
actually did he's got a bit of a temper
but he was exercising remarkable self
restraint and when he's when the second
girl was assaulted he said we can't
trust this system anymore i mean we've
got to just take it into our own hands
did you ever come across john dewey when
you were studying the history of the
school system yeah this guy seems
pervasive this psychologist he was right
there with the rockefeller foundation
getting started i don't know did he
start a foundation or anything i haven't
really looked too deep into him yet so i
mean i think they they were all based
out of columbia university and that's
also kind of the epicenter of critical
race theory tracing it back to critical
theory james lindsay probably told you
all about that he knows way more than me
um but there's some creepy stuff
happening in columbia university
teachers college in the in the 50s and
60s
and uh yeah a lot a lot of bad stuff
came out of there and that's where the
foundations basically started funding
social science which is not a real
science it's just activism yeah but they
create a lot of papers that get before
these local governments and things like
that so you can go to all these meetings
your town council or whatever but they
put this paper it looks really
complicated it's got a lot of jargon in
it and that's one of the things with the
schools too that struck me as they have
their own language that is designed to
keep people out it creates a barrier to
entry because you don't know their
acronyms and you know i learned about
all that through the course of writing
the book the acronyms are stupid i can
explain them all i know what they mean
but you know for the regular people
they're not missing out on anything the
language is artificially indeed
needlessly complex for the sole purpose
of keeping regular people out of their
own uh town government thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there